welcome to another exciting edition of
are you garbage the show where you find
out if your favorite comedians are
classy individuals or absolute trash
now here are your hosts kevin ryan and h
foley hey
everybody out there and welcome back to
everybody's favorite new podcast this is
are you garbage
little show we sit down your favorite
comedians and we find that they're going
to be classy you after a big old piece
of trash i'm your host dave's foley
coming at you on a glorious day down
here in aunt toddy's basement but i'm
going to tell you folks cause you're the
homies the patriots that's right we're
here for
oh yeah having a good time over here
i love each and every one of you despite
what you said about me in the last seven
days my co-host is coming at you from
across the table he's my goddamn boss do
me a favor i'm in the hole with this guy
shoot me a [ __ ] yelp review or
something like that i think they did
already it ain't good service was there
give me five stars i'll take four and a
half something make me look good this
guy's getting ready to kick me to the
curb oh look at him
rolling over playing victim already
give it up for kj i'm thinking about
changing to just kev
the beer jackets you're a cat no beer
jackets are kj i feel no kj wouldn't
wear that kev kev is the cool guy he's
still hanging around the area didn't go
to college he's doing pretty good your
stock's really rising
everybody loves you
i'm a nice guy who's not a psychopath a
liar yeah toby
speaking to toby mcmullen our good pal
the magic man another kid [ __ ]
killing it dude i'm [ __ ] falling
behind here they used to love me
now i'm the bad boy
the bad boy you're really buttering us
up for this one aren't you oh yeah uh
t-bone mcmuffin toby mcmullen is
the gentleman
from north carolina's name
what's up hey pal i got presents for you
guys by the way oh nice says no
i just wanted to give a quick shout out
to all the new kitchen staff over the
last couple of days uh you're doing a
great job in there because we're [ __ ]
cooking patreon's cooking all right
before we get into everything we just
you know we hit the 3600 so the 10 000
bet will be happening
very very soon once foley has five
thousand dollars so it could be six to
eight years who the [ __ ] knows
well we'll we'll take that from the the
nut
i think we might even take it from the
ad money first okay because we gotta we
want to get that out we wanna [ __ ]
shake while they're on top because we
had to push [ __ ] the disney thing due
to the tour so like i want to [ __ ]
get this done i mean you know and get
this and give it to the [ __ ] patrons
they [ __ ] you know they rallied
behind it and
uh i really want to [ __ ] i want to you
know so we should be getting that but
they we just got jammed up with that
money they're really giving me the
[ __ ] run around who is the old ad
company uh oh god i didn't know this got
bought by a big ad company really
and now like everything's done online so
i hit the guy i'm like hey man you never
sent me the breakdown for the
payment this month uh-huh and he goes
that's all done online now you got to
set up an account at [ __ ] jg
wentworth or whatever well it's my money
and i want it now it's kevin's money and
i want it now
so but yeah so i think we're gonna do
that so that you know we should you
should have some of that money and then
we can you know use uh
apply that towards the ten thousand
dollar bet sounds great that'll be the
greatest night or the worst night of my
life it's gonna be fun either way it's
going to ruin my summer how do you think
we should do it before we go we have a
lot to get to i don't know i.e the new
fat challenge i don't know how we're
going to film it to be honest once we
get into the casino it's going to be
dicey fake fake cell phone i also want
to get you you can go you can buy like
glasses i thought about those that would
be funny just to like have you going
like all right here we go we're going in
even if it's like grainy and whatever
it'll still be fun yeah and then i think
you could do like the problem with the
with the cell phone jack like cell phone
pocket that was my that was gonna be one
of the moves for sure and if we all do
that and we have three [ __ ] cam three
cell phones running at the table
why are you guys all wearing the same
glasses no i'm saying if t-bone has the
glasses the glasses only record for like
30 seconds at a time though
you only need that [ __ ] you just need
you looking at the thing as it's
bouncing around we're going blink blink
plate
uh there we're sure we'll get audio
without a question sure because we'll
just [ __ ] i think you can pull your
phone out
even if you stand back like in the
hallway like if you're not at the table
the hallway where are we doing that like
what the walkway like because that's
like technically not the floor hold on
that's an idea
like if you're just even back if you're
like five feet behind i honestly think i
honestly think if i film it vertically
on a phone no one will say [ __ ] i think
it's a [ __ ] instagram story yeah of
course that's what i'm saying
i think you gave me an idea with the
hallway instead of going to national
casino we go to somebody's casino night
and clean out some church
not a bad idea
no
what you know the baptist church isn't
going to take a ten thousand dollar bet
all right they got a bake sale they
gotta cover and send a couple of drinks
over to the table will you padre
gonna [ __ ] get this wine from huh
yikes
um very exciting
yeah we'll figure it out but like should
we also do like a nice dinner
like
what's the night after
but that might ruin the dinner i think
what we appreciate what we need to do
the night's ruined we're going to lose
and i'm going to be serious all three of
us are doing this we need to take the
ten thousand dollars out for a nice
night of the town like go around with
the staff that's pretty funny like have
him at the table and stuff
he'll have the pellet green we'll put
we'll put the little eyes on him
tap water for him please
we don't know how long he's sticking
around
uh
yeah i don't know i think if we go to a
nice dinner and you have like the
build-off it'll be fun we'll be so
[ __ ] anxious i'll be boozing heavy to
forget about it to shut the old memory
off
and then if we win we'll go out and
we'll buy like a bottle or something
somewhere if not we'll go to that dive
bar you have to have the money on you
right when you go in did i ask you this
what i don't know if you venmo or
whatever i don't gamble
all right yeah we're driving down with
10 jihads cash money nervous in ones
so we look cool
i was thinking we should run a big call
because akash might come down obviously
ooh a little star oh i forgot about that
that doubles the bet to twenty thousand
why when there was something else of
if we win we're doing it
if we win we put like
grand on a number i don't know if it was
a thousand it was something it was
something along those lines we'd do
another a secondary bet jesus christ
whatever i have to go back and listen to
that said uh
it's a sad thing the loud mouth promises
we made
we really run our [ __ ] yaps huh yes
we do we keep it interesting over here
it made us got us this far so let's keep
doing it a million dollars next time
this has nothing to do with the new
weigh-in and the new challenge no all
right but i got i was in wawa and i got
you guys uh
a little present just because we were
talking about them the other day
tops baseball cards yeah pack of
baseball cards great
of course
but you got a trash can over there
no this is great i always wanted this
this is
wow it's not your [ __ ] birthday
present [ __ ] i just saw it we were
talking about baseball cards so i got
you a pack and the angels too my
favorite theme it's not just the angels
that's who's on the cover
you probably took the gum out of here
already didn't you
snickers let's see what we got here
holy michael jordan rookie card holy
[ __ ] also what kind of [ __ ] it says
16 cards and then
may contain only 9 to 14 cards
what kind of bozo [ __ ] did you get me
you're a dirtbag through and through
yeah i got the ace of clubs what's going
on here
man talk about getting this screwdriver
anybody good no i got a met off rip
there's a couple of good guys on that
team piazza who you
needs a new crv like piazza motors yeah
if he's in there selling the cars i
doubt it maybe just on the weekends
orioles brewers they stink so lay this
out what's the skill all right so
obviously hold on well we were thinking
thank you paulie of course this actually
you know
this was sparked by tom cassidy
of uh you know the ayg live shows i
don't know if you already said he's a
worker over there on a live show yes he
is hey man hey man when are you gonna do
something that was along those lines hey
man what's gonna happen
um
i think this was probably the first time
he spent seven days with you or so
and it did come at the end of the trip
yeah his
you know his like uh whatever you want
to call it
yes uh
if you're not a 10 homie
you might not know what's going on over
there sure i had a rough weekend cali i
messed up a couple of times you ended up
costing it costing the company about
i don't know you know
at least three grand closer to
conservative yeah that's very
conservative
but we hashed it out on hard feelings
emergency hard feelings yes
so
i'm digging my way out of a little hole
here what you got going on over there
you got the little hiccups you're like
hansey when he drinks too much toilet
water that's exactly how i got it
blue stuff is delicious um
so
and it's honestly in a you know
uh
we've been down this road many times but
it's not many times enough uh
it honestly from a genuine place you
know
emotion it has been
weighing on me no pun intended i swear
to god
uh you really do see
the behaviors when you're with when
you're together for a week
you know what i mean you see
you know i i just see how do you feel
about my eating habits in cali
if you had a graded from an a to an f
minus yes c minus
that's passing
c is getting bob we're going to college
community
for three years i'll try to answer i
thought you would have said d uh yeah it
wasn't good i think you were being
polite it wasn't good i wasn't i don't
know why i know um you have this effect
on it he does you want your facebook you
want his affection you want his
attention
yeah um squeeze a c out of you in no
time
um
okay a c all right let's go let's call
let's call a spade it was a d
i d i the extracurricular activities
weren't fantastic i didn't i didn't
snack in between any meals
i kept it pretty tight with the meals
nope not this is i and like from a non
we talked about this a little bit on the
hard feelings that came out yesterday
that we shot by the pool are you
referring to the sweet potato french
fries
bread the bread
the yeah there's something i have that
had bread you order bread every time you
order bread every breakfast oh
i have a slice of toast i know but you'd
like this and i think i think this is
you know
we we did talk about this and i think
the disconnect is you're going i had a
slice of bread
when it's really minimum two slices of
bread and the potatoes
and you you never know where you ordered
like a whole pastry and then pretended
like you didn't know what it was when it
showed up what was that ah the canis
oh yeah yeah the ganesh and then got mad
at us that you had to eat a healthy
lunch
a healthier lunch i'm sitting here
eating [ __ ] toppings you're like
honestly that's what it's like to go out
with you
that wasn't that healthy i had two
scoops of tuna fish and a scoop of egg
salad i know but you're sitting there
complaining by the way cantor's by the
way
sucks but
yeah sucks ass that place needed a power
you call that a [ __ ] pickle
uh yeah they were like sorry
they really wilted those things oh man
um i think
i think there's a big disconnect in
reality to your delusion of what healthy
is
because you know and i was thinking
about this
i also think i'm batman
i probably should tell you guys
[Music]
[Laughter]
tune in next week same fat time same fat
channel same dinner time
so fat there's grease on the buttons
would you like a cigarette
it's a lot it's
what are your thoughts
on cantors
on the white fish
i'll tell you what i know you think
you're coming from and then we'll we'll
go from there i thought i skated by
pretty good i mean obviously the
potatoes at see i never know what you
guys are picking up dude everything you
eat everything fully everything it's
just i'll just ruin the meal if i tell
you how i feel yeah yes you would
um
you did a great job of that
breakfast that one day he did kind of
ruin breakfast oh we'll we'll we'll get
to that once we address the discussion
at breakfast
sure um
i handled that very well i thought at
the time he did i do think he had the
right
to lose it on you you were being very
[ __ ]
in front of a
associate by the way yeah
an associate yeah um
i didn't snack at all in between any
meals which is one thing i'll say of
course that's yeah but yes of course i
will do whatever you know i'll do
what i can i'll i'll get away with what
you think you can get away with yeah
which is the the
crux of the problem
you have no interest in bettering
yourself for you you only want to do it
so we don't give you [ __ ] that's all so
you're not making that you're making the
choices of
i can see it in your face like i said i
know you're going like oh if i go
pancakes that's going to be a [ __ ]
pushback that i don't want right now so
i'll go omelette with a side of [ __ ]
whatever and whatever and you're real
big on sides by the way don't think i
haven't noticed and then also as they're
like okay they're collecting menus like
oh yeah and a triple stack of paint
you're like real you really throw it
together like it just came into your
little blooper in the left field
just a little pop a pop fly
a pop fly ice cream sundae if you will
try to score runs here
play a money ball a little pop pancake
flight huh um you know
side of coleslaw
uh yeah you're real big on this no but
let's go over it okay so so what i
should have had at breakfast would just
be bacon and eggs maybe or just i just
say hey i'll take a uh feta spinach
omelette and a side of bacon and that's
that okay i got you yes and that's not
even i'm not i'm not sitting here going
that's the most healthiest thing sure
tacos you know the tacos i thought that
was pretty good nope nope no good those
tacos i mean man what about
savory treats dude
i've never had it before i thought it
was a dude i don't believe it i thought
it was a birthday cake when they dropped
it i
i was expecting like 46 to be on top oh
the waiters start singing happy happy
fat guy happy happy fat guy uh i didn't
i honestly didn't really know what beef
wellington was and i was like oh me i
figured it was like cut of beef and like
some
gravy or something i was thinking like
you know
like a tenderloin type thing man that
thing that thing came out
that was like a doughnut dude
i didn't [ __ ] say nothing though did
i no you didn't and you i didn't give
you [ __ ] at all this whole thing very
very merciful
very very very very v very kind very
forgiving
i also
me i'm talking about sure i
this is gonna sound like this is
i'm trying to be honest and genuine here
man you know uh and you told me not like
let's keep it fun and lightheart like
you know i'm not i i don't want to yell
we've been down all these roads you know
and uh
i do
i think
i've given up to be honest
i don't
i don't know if i have it in me
just because like after you know
hey we're on the road everybody gives up
on the road if we're in [ __ ] albany
or [ __ ]
you know hey [ __ ] we're behind the gun
we just gotta eat real quick or it's mad
late and you know hey i'll get the
whatever the what that like you know we
tend to turn blind eyes to a lot of that
stuff
um
i think i think
for storyline
for the homies
believing in me
we've hit rock bottom and i'm aware of
that yeah i think i i think you've lost
all i mean this is going on a year now
we did the last challenge i think was
was probably a year ago we started the
weight loss challenge right we're at
rock bottom i don't expect anybody to
believe me which is why i wasn't such a
cunted breakfast i understand if you if
i if you're turning your listen i know
i'm down in the polls right now with
with the hope and this but this is also
this is
this is not fat foley this is now
[ __ ]
manipulator foley goal i know i'm down
in the polls i know i've hurt you i i i
know i've i know i've stolen from you
but i'm a changed man this is what's
this that's why i was such a gun because
i genuinely believed in you and you
broke my heart
and my chair
i'm sitting in a broken chair
also shout out to beef wellington
don't blame me
blame that scottish bastard that
invented that thing because it's
delicious and not uh
not a
uh this is just outside looking in again
a week a full week together going
everywhere doing everything all day
today you know um
the late night tuna fish sandwich at
that bar was probably
that was crazy that you did that that
was like i mean if you would have been
like give me a meatball sub i was like
at that point i'm 13 i'm [ __ ] uh
probably 19 beers deep i'm looking for a
tuna fish you don't know what to say
tuna fish say i was more like that's
insane that you're gonna eat tuna fish
from a place
that there's there's there's running
water on the floor it was unbelievable
they did have really good food oh my god
that place was recommended by like 15 15
people to us you let me have a couple
did i have a wing did you let me have a
wing
i think i did have a wing yeah me dude
you ate everything that we got you ate
the chips the wings you're big on chips
too and a side of chip that's your
tortillas yeah you're big on one of
these and one of those but
again this is
uh
i don't want to make it seem like i'm
beating you up or anything like that
this is coming from a point of like
your weight is a thing on the road
um
i mean just at like
seating tables
booths chairs it's like everything it's
gotten to the point i'm not being a dick
this isn't for comedy this is more of
like
it's bigger than just your weight
problem when you're traveling
i mean it's like what car seat you get
in who sits next to you he hasn't put me
in a car seat no but i'm just saying
like
tommy's got to ride a dude first of all
we have we do we have an suv that holds
15 people and tommy rides up front
and it's just me you and tommy but i'm
just saying it's you're you're you know
your weight
affects every movement ultimately on the
road it's considered
plus the airlines you got to think about
too they're spending extra gas
they're already jammed up we got we got
lucky on the way back though and i do
think you smoking the sig
to me
there was pure laziness
smoking the cigarette in the driveway
that's pure pure laziness
because it never would have crossed my
mind to have one there
i think that you going i ain't i'm done
it's late in the night i don't have i've
i've walked i don't have it in me i'm
just gonna smoke right here okay
yeah so i would argue
us getting tossed
was
slightly related to your
situation by obesity sure well i know
you feel that way and i'm this is coming
from love this is coming from like i'm
trying to make you
aware of the tasks at hand sure if that
makes sense sure there are still some
some of the homies out there that
believe me um
oh so i went through it out there
what he's on the patreon
oh yeah yeah it was open season with a
big man which all just deserved as well
i'll admit that right now i deserve
every bit of it that's a little harsh
listen we've been having a good time
over here we very much live and die
our personal lives on this patreon which
i think is why it's very popular we era
you know we air our stuff out there's we
haven't had this conversation off air
yeah you know what i mean like i'm
saying this one of these bozos that
don't have the balls to lay it all out
there on the line that's what we do
every week like an open nerve which also
like it makes it easier
the fact that we are recording i don't
know if i would be able to say that to
you that your weight is like affecting
the trips okay you know what i don't
know if i'd be able to say that to you
off air i feel easier to do here
because you can't really you can't throw
a punch at me
[Laughter]
i flinch i make them think you're
beating me
you can't sit in a booth
um
which i'm off like again i'm all fine
with it's it's you know it's i'm not
complaining about that i'm just going
like it is
sound a little bit like a complaint no
i'm sharing with you that like when we
walk into a place appetizers it's like
fully what
where do you want i gotcha what do you
want the booth or do you want the tape
and then when you whatever you do take
that tables get moved about two three
feet by the way
it's okay so
i'm aware of this i'm aware that that
that you know nobody's going to believe
in me for the because we're gearing up
for another weight loss challenge
pretty much which i i'm i'm throwing
down the gauntlet
once again because i got the big man in
my pocket for about 35 on though nope 28
i paid you to four i paid for the hotels
chickens new airbnb was
3 500. wasn't it or 2800. 28. maybe
2800. the total was three
plus i called the hotel and checked
their rates yeah then you sure changed
me no that's the case i was saying 400
it was four something and you really got
away with hey saying to 400 let me know
and i will send it right over okay
minus the baseball cards
the nine to 12 baseball cards
so anyway i get i get the chips are down
um
[Laughter]
right
ruffles
there was never a big ruffles guy the
chips are down and can we get some more
salsa
the chips are down
got hot sauce
where did we have chips and salsa
everywhere
[Laughter]
i caught you having them in bed one
night
no you're in there with a lady it was
just a tostitos bag
i heard the squeaking you were humping
her not a regular ruffles guy but the
the cheddar sour cream ones are pretty
off the hook yeah they were two two two
grease they're too too much stuff on
them they're very hard those those
ruffles they don't [ __ ] around with
those stuff i was thinking hers ripples
no ruffles the red bag
rough red bag oh no
that's her bad chip
version of ruffles those things are
[ __ ] like a quarter it's thick
that'll stop a stinger missile those
things put those on [ __ ] tanks and
stuff
jesus christ anyway not to get off track
yeah so hold on so all your concerns all
your comments are warranted
someone do a compilation of him saying
the same [ __ ] over and over all that's
sincere all in the same shirt by the way
and you say the same thing every time i
call you i'm serious this time but just
so everybody knows we don't want anybody
getting upset on the patreon or dividing
the room or anything like that just
holding a severed head i will not kill
again
this guy had it coming
i mean we don't you can't have any loose
ends walking around i don't want people
to take it too seriously it's like can't
have any burnt ends left on his plate
barbecue
was it again i don't know that was you
you lost confidence before you even
finished the party i knew that you
wouldn't know what burton ends were i
heard burnt ends and that's what that's
what peaked my interest cause they are
delicious um
so tommy tommy
okay i'm gonna say
we don't want anybody taking things do
you you're not really mad at me
no two yeah no the show's not in any
jeopardy of going away anything like
that no never and you know i appreciate
it
you know i i appreciate that you guys
care care about us enough to to you know
to to to you know be mad and you should
be mad i've let yous all down i'll be
the first one to admit it i've let you
all down second one to admit it
i've let you zold down
but and for the record i am not mad at
you but i have lost all faith in you
completely
it's just where i want to be baby
just what i wanted
so
everybody loves to come back
you said this like
[ __ ]
12 months ago
10 months ago a second come back
come back come back i got you right
where i want you
so
um
and this week so tommy brought something
up tommy cassidy tommy cassie just like
in a very genuine way
was just like
what are we going to do here like you
was i there yeah i forgot the comment
but it was like what
come on in new guys new guy luke
my only friend in the company hey buddy
good to see you yeah wait till luke's
pays late
because you lost us 35 grand in
california
um
tommy just it was just like a very it
was just a very
calm
comment of like
what are we doing here i forget the
exact words but it was like are we just
going to keep
you you know you were about six ipas
deep there was like you know all sorts
of apps sprinkled the infield and you
were
you were dabbling hang on one second
yeah i got you some baseball cards buddy
continue
so tommy just made a comment of
something very that kind of it shook me
to the core because it wasn't a joke
right it wasn't like you fat pc [ __ ] you
bald it like it it was just like at the
end of him spending a week with you he
was just like what are
something's got we got to do something
here
um and then obviously the shirtless
picture you're going around isn't doing
yet a whole bunch of favors in you know
here's the crazy thing you think you
look good
i i know that i look better in that
picture than i do in real life actually
of course if you saw me now i mean but
that's a lot of man you're a lot of man
in that picture big dude
back is fighting and the worst thing
about it is the front is like a thousand
times worse bad that's what i'm saying
it's like niagara falls over your belt
buckle dude it's i got the uh the bobby
the bobby buckley area
from soprano oh the stomach he had i
thought you had man he had his own like
fat guy waistbands or something
that's like
i come in here dressed like paulie
walnuts everybody i thought that's what
you meant like he's got a girdle or
something i'm like all right i didn't
know i didn't know he's diversified like
that
new bobby buckley aries girl i thought i
literally thought it was like some sort
of stomach
suspender that's good so
yes
i do
i'm losing it i think
i do think we're at a tipping point
right after this past year of if you
don't do it now i and i'm not being a
dick i genuinely don't think you have it
in you after watching your behavior
over the past year not just based on
anything like i genuinely
i don't think you have it in you
okay
i understand that and i understand your
doubts i think it would be insane if i
thought you did have it in you i'd have
to check myself into a mental
institution if i believed in you at 2 4.
i understand um
but i do think you're getting to the
point where it's like you something
something's gotta
give you gotta do
something man okay something well let's
get into show
let's start to move forward yes of
course okay
because like i said we don't want
anybody
you know don't go dying on us no no it's
not that it's just you know i don't want
to i get worried i don't want to turn
the the homies off i don't want to start
hating me
no one hates you oh buddy too late for
that
i was trying to be nice i'm like no one
hates you
welcome to the dark side fatty
we crossed that line somewhere in the
hollywood hills
you play a good bad guy i am the bad guy
um
no so you know so you're i
conservative number
conservative number you're into us
you're into the company for
28 jihad if i really had if i was a
business putting an actual well which i
know
which i know you don't have by the way
either way for the record i've agreed i
said i will i will take care of that and
you really bri i will take care of that
the words pay never came out i will do
that thing you mentioned with the other
guy and the thing luke i need a one-way
flight to cancun
take care of it leah the only guy i can
trust
that's when you know it's real bad when
i'm calling you on a friday night don't
tell the other guys
um
right did you just yeah just trying to
save my name a little bit i offered to
pay it you guys came up with this
well it's also you know
i know you ain't got it
i'll have it on the first
it'll be gone on the second
i'll have half of it on the first
it's like the prestige [ __ ]
last thing i say abracadabra
great movie by the way michael caine's
just looking at your finances losing his
mind ow is he doing this
it's impossible
he owed me he owed me 400 for the hotel
rooms and he goes i'll get that to you
next week i go you don't have 400 he
didn't have 400 personally i was cash
poor at the time
that just means you're poor dude
i know you don't have stocks well i know
you don't take amex
[Laughter]
considering if you i am
i start reductive number you're like
wait a minute sounds so bad all right so
kippy it's your billing address
name on the card kevin j ryan
oh that's funny anywho
the number
we put on you is 2 800 2800 okay
uh and i think that's so let's do a
little quick little math here i own my
own company 2800
that's insane dude
is that not an accurate statement no i
mean
it's insane that that's a statement
it's not like
the company should owe you money
but you know the company currently owes
me thirteen hundred dollars
theoretically yes not theoretically the
company one hundred percent owes me
thirteen hundred dollars for an airbnb
hypothetically
no factually
statistically
okay thirteen hundred dollars i don't
know the difference but but but go ahead
um so really that's all i really do oh
is 1300. no this is for something else
this is for an airbnb another air this
is for chicago no you owe more than 28
you owe more than 2 800
because if you want to look at it the
other place was like 800 a night and we
lost two or three nights there
okay so that would be 800 times 3 that
would be 2 400 plus the 2 800. well go
ahead give me the real number let's go i
don't need any [ __ ] training wheels
on it i'll [ __ ] take my medicine like
a big boy 3 600
no it's more than that 36. it would be
50
200 or something like that
oh yeah i said one night oh my god he
means the knights then we lost at the
end we paid for
if you prorated a night
let's call it i think it was like i'll
even i'm guessing 700 a night
times what nights did we lose uh
wednesday thursday friday what smells
like cherry
wednesday thursday
friday
so yeah okay so
you run down to grab me a laffy taffy or
something jesus christ that's killing me
right now
it smells good yours doesn't smell like
that
i wouldn't oh luke's rocking the
bernie's tea too no way to get on my
ears company man huh oh there you go
take that off the top by the way you get
some rec specs look at you you pay
retail for that
so it's technically the number is 4 900.
okay which is fine it makes it even a
little more incentive
so
you're into the company for 4 900. i'm
sitting there
you just ran your yap into two more
cheeses it's okay
it's okay
this is literally how the first one
started hey man can you lose five pounds
i'll lose 400 pounds tomorrow all right
so
um
let's let's just call it for for math's
sake let's call it uh 4 800. for for
example call it five grand that's
because that doesn't work with math
that's perfect yes it does 14 it's
another 100.
yes it's just called 4800 a thousand
the number we're using is 4 800. okay um
i'll go 48.5 just
you just can't agree with things that's
what it is in your head anything
you you gotta you gotta move it you
gotta put your little pizzazz on it
48.51 all right
um
so 1200 so that's 1200 that'll be you so
we're gonna put you don't have the 4
cash am i correct on that i don't want
to assume your personal finances but i'm
gonna
hey hey henry can you get the checkbook
out and call me a check for 48. can you
cut to the llc a check for 4 800
right now yeah
i don't have a pen i mean
[Laughter]
it's a weekend
it's a holiday weekend so
jesus didn't die to die so i could
bounce a check on a monday
i am doing the collection of mass on
something yes sticky fingers though
[Laughter]
hey can we run this one more time
you ever see them counting the money in
the back no but i remember that when
they started doubling up on the baskets
my dad got real pissed i was like you
believe these [ __ ] they do it twice
yeah that what that started in the 90s
they got a lot of legal fees yeah and
also they were like redoing the gym or
something my dad's like listen you get a
cool dub every time i'm not [ __ ]
you're not getting 40 out of me
i'm not even taking communion
i'm not even eating
[Laughter]
i'll pay for the drinks but that's it
man
okay so
you don't have the 4 800.
that's correct i do not have the 4 800.
all i wanted from you fair enough i'm
giving you giving it
just that one or put you on a we're
going to put you so this was two right
though this is your your your weight
gain
and then also
your debt
and i've decided to join these two
things which is listen for content all
jokes
for content purposes of course it's all
content folks we're having a good time
but i will say
best boss i ever had
best friend i ever had and i love you
and i i appreciate it
moving on
you thought that was going to get me no
i'm just saying like i can see it
clearly you know this is this is nice
that you're doing this of course
um
i'm being sincere
um
so
we'll do four so i'll break that
into four monthly payments of twelve
hundred dollars
okay man that's a lot of scratch
i would like to add an addendum to this
hold on so let me just let me explain
the original uh addendum the original
contract [ __ ] ben franklin over here
and then we can add some addendums to
fit our steve what's an addendum an
addition it's not an appetizer just keep
it moving that's gonna say do they come
with a sign of guacamole
can i get extra chips with my addendum
please
i shouldn't have even tried it
i was
he was like he dude he takes one like
this thing sucks i look over it's gone
supposed to use about a gallon of
mustard on it i assumed you idiots
wouldn't know what it is this is what he
thinks of us
you think we know what a ganesh is yeah
you thought that i thought you didn't
know what you ordered
in what world does a man this fat not
know the food he's asking for that
seinfeld
had a vibe though also that beef
wellington in hindsight is an egregious
choice
for lunch he had beef wellington some
dinner dude with like 15 ipa we were
getting tanked up what do you mean
that's what they have on sundays for
their roasts yeah i think we ordered
yeah dude it's like once a year i've
never had one it's a better time than
noon when it's a hundred degrees out
and you're drinking
gordon ramsay's always talking about him
yeah for dinner
and holiday parties
not day drinking with the boys
that's that's like sitting down and
ordering a [ __ ] thanksgiving dinner
that's insane
can i get some pretzel rods and a whole
turkey
yeah i mean me and todd me and tommy got
like happening we got like a fish and
chips and like whatever you know what i
mean we're hanging dude that beef
wellington dropped and i oh man that was
crazy
came with one of those big [ __ ]
stainless steel thing
[Laughter]
so
the original bet was
and we can we can no bet the original
deal no bet the original deal was i will
waive
a monthly
payment
the original deal because i
not comedy-wise or not being a dick i
have ye of little faith and i want the
ball just to start moving in the right
direction we tried with to lose the 25
pounds in a month i don't want anything
to do with that i said
if you lose any weight if you weigh in
lower than what you weighed in the month
before which i could lose a pound a
month i would be happy you're putting on
two at this point
again with this let me do that this is
what got you into the trouble the last
time
you can't do that if you could do that
you would be doing that so like this
this whole guy i can't let you do that
also you shouldn't let me put you on a
[ __ ] payment plan why not
he's well i mean like you're like i
can't take you 1200 for four pounds
or you're like i won't take the 4800 for
four pounds i mean i should just be
paying it
yeah i feel you should be in a position
where you just or you don't get us
[ __ ] kicked out of the airbnb which i
can't go back and change that but
there'll be no trouble for me moving
forward
sure i believe you talked about separate
accommodations
yeah that you'll be paying for yeah if
we go somewhere you'll get a [ __ ]
hotel room wait hold on i don't like
that am i banned from airbnbs obviously
dude really you cost us four grand i
didn't cost you anything
that's true you get paid regardless yes
um who said you won
you cost me four grand yeah
and then locked me out of the new airbnb
allegedly i had to pay for that i had to
pay for hotel rooms for me and tommy
then you sure changed me on the venmo
request i didn't you you told me it was
foreign hey
comedy purposes remember sure before
he's like don't get mad in this one
let's have fun
now i'm breaking your stones over here
first of all you're like i'll send you
the six bucks but the 52 hundo you're
out on the hook for
fair enough so
yeah you'll pay for your i i mean that's
like hedging our bets i can't have you
in more airbnbs really i didn't know
that
yeah you'll get a hotel room is there
any way to wiggle myself back in there
let's see when's it when's the next
airbnb coming in chicago
really
so i had to pay two nights for my own
hotel
i'd rather pay yes i mean also
t-shirt money
if you come to the chicago show there's
gonna be a bucket going around you live
in a wild you're doing two buckets two
collection plates i made a lighter
candle on the back for the airbnb man i
tell you what if i had a couple of those
long things going around at the end of
the show that'd be all right
i mean never so whatever i don't know
we'll cross that bridge when we get to
it but
oh no the next airbnb is in [ __ ]
austin this week next week the first
night we got an airbnb
we just came to i mean hotel rooms for
the three of us ended up costing us
[ __ ] 700 a night or whatever between
three people are we in an airbnb for
sunday and monday
or is you just hoteling it
i don't know i don't know we're not that
far yet okay um
so
can i just say this
i guess we've had numerous airbnbs
that i'd never had a problem in
this guy was an extra special
[ __ ] prick and i walked right into
his trap i'll admit that
but you got to give me another chance
with the airbnb we did and you locked us
out and i had to get a hotel room at two
in the morning [ __ ] i forgot about that
i meant
the whole airbnb no no no no
you are a certain kind of doofus
the whole week
you realize
how big of an idiot you are right
you just sat there and fought give me
one more shot and you already hung
yourself
okay one more shot
we'll see maybe i don't know okay
that's a yes
well i mean at what point do you go guys
i'll just get a hotel room to stop
inconveniencing you guys like at some
point the burden's on you you're making
the burden on me like you should be like
hey guys i'm going to be a good team
this is what i would do if i caused the
chaos you caused in la i'd be like
listen guys it's obviously way cheaper
for you guys to get airbnbs you guys do
that i've proven i can't handle myself
and be responsible as a team player
they're not paying we're paying for the
airbnb
okay
i'm saying what i would do
you still locked other people out of
their [ __ ] hotel room whether you're
out of the airbnb whether you're paying
it or not you don't get to [ __ ] just
do that
you're not going to go hey tommy just
because we're taking on the road [ __ ]
tough noogies
ah poor tommy he was out there for a
while there for like 90 minutes
didn't help those creeps across the
street with the [ __ ] halloween decker
i'm just saying i think i would be like
listen guys if in the times when it is
financially
beneficial to get airbnbs for more than
one night stays with a group of people
you guys can get one for three people
i'll get a hotel room
do i have to book the hotel myself
i mean you can i mean like again this is
like your mom doing your laundry
can you book a hotel room yourself you
seem to do it in hawaii and [ __ ]
paris i don't you never locked anybody
out did you are you locking everybody
out in hawaii so you're not doing the
laundry um
whatever we're getting off we're getting
off track
well it's coming up this weekend i gotta
i gotta make a move i gotta get on
expedia i gotta find out i'm gonna get
bamboozled over the rates oh
boohoo i am i feel so bad you're hitting
me now
can i come by and hang out at the airbnb
no guess that's my rule ten grand uh
whatever five thousand dollars yeah
we're getting off track here
so
what let's all the the three of us and
maybe even luke throws his uh
cool guy hat in the ring here um
so
we're gonna weigh you today
whatever that is excuse me one second
your next your next weigh-in just wanted
to intimidate new guy luke real quick
your next weigh-in will be on or around
the 15th depending on i'm sorry can you
repeat that your next weigh-in from
today will be on or around the 15th
ironically that is the same day your
first 1200
payment is due where
to me okay not ironically you set it up
like that
this guy's and he of course yeah it's
also my first my first tax payment still
um which can i say that yeah got that
all taken care of
a per payment plan automatic payment
plan
i'm all set i did all i i looked up got
all my stuff got everything organized
they sent her over the accountant the
tax thing is is is being handled and as
you said that was the biggest step yeah
but this is also like wellington
we just lit the house on fire and gone
but i tied my shoes today
hey
hey fire department look whose shoes are
tied
joke's on you i didn't tie my shoes my
mom did it for me when i left oh she
didn't
i don't know if i was a guy who's tied
your shoes i don't know if i believe
that this guy's tied my shoe that's a
good friend huh not this son of a [ __ ]
trying to throw me under the [ __ ] bus
all right you wouldn't fit
that's true
i'll be a [ __ ] up boss
i'm not paying for that
you better have bumper to bumper on his
goddamn bus
he hit me de blasio whatever
so one month from today your first 1200
payment
to today is due
which it was 700
and somebody started running their mail
yeah you
which i now regret but also i think this
works better because when you do sit
down to have a cheeseburger and you can
you've rationalized in your head
that could cause that could be a 1200
cheeseburger you're about to have
maybe some truffles on that or what i'm
saying
slice of bread or beer bread or ipa
listen you like to drink buddy i like to
drink too i like a cocktail i'm not even
doing the ipa you're getting [ __ ] up
and forgetting
[ __ ] seven
ipas as you're having a beef wellington
i mean it's crazy everybody else we're
all sitting at the table and i'm a fat
tubby [ __ ] though i'm not trying to sit
here like i'm an adonis but i'm i'm
trying to be like all right well that's
at least a thousand different calories a
thousand additional calories i'm not
having it the martinis aren't working
out either because i drink about 15 of
them
yeah and then lock us out of the airbnb
right sure whatever so one week from
today or one month from today your first
1200 payment is due yes whatever this is
let's just say this number is
400 even by whatever it is it's not
going to be that but guy that's fine i
don't buddy no judgment there's no
judgments
no judgment we agree on that you guys
got to check him
what no judgments on how much i actually
before we do the weigh-in what is the
number
he's got to lose for the payment to be
waived
also like let's let's review it this way
i want he's like a small town judge it's
they'll say a hundred pounds no no this
guy's really at the gym
they say healthy weight loss is one
pound a week so i think somewhere in
between four and five pounds
i'll say
i'll save four pounds if you can lose
four pounds a month
well
we'll weigh we'll wave each
actually let's say five let's say five
pounds i thought it was going to be 10.
you buddy no one's going to stop you at
five if you want to lose 10 lose 10
because you want to be like i'm four at
the end of this you want to go i'm 40
pounds down please please lose 10.
you're you see that your brain's already
warped in the sense that i'm dictating
what you can lose or not that's the way
you're looking at it
i would like i just want you to doubt me
as much as possible couldn't possibly
doubt you anymore dude
thanks buddy
uh i would like to propose an addendum
to the court also hold on with your
addendums
so well i say i'd say five pounds i
think that's fair
water fluctuation taking dumb i mean you
could clear out five
pretty easy
[ __ ] that's working well that's what
i'm saying don't make it so easy on me
plus i want the homies to have
for them
if you start losing if you lose five
pounds in four months everybody's gonna
be [ __ ] i'll cry
five pounds in four months five pounds
every month for four months what's that
25 pounds 20 pounds 20 pounds
four months
yeah
i could do better than that but okay
please this is what you don't understand
please do better and you keep saying
that and you're getting fatter now so
like hold on you can't do better than
that if i lose you say you can't do
better than that i can't do better than
what
loose you're saying you can lose more
than five pounds in a month uh-huh
admit that you can't do that because you
haven't done it
history will dictate that that i
couldn't but let me ask you this
if i lose 10
no do i get 1200 no no okay bye let's
focus on five
and my addendum was going to be
if the court approves it obviously
that if you miss
not only do you owe the money
the juice
starts running putting a vig on it ten
percent
ten percent what a month
correct
i don't know how that works
ten percent of the payment or ten
percent of the principal you you would
owe ten percent more
you would get juiced for 10
on top of what you already owe
so if i owe 5 grand
you would add 500 to that that is
correct ah
okay
i don't agree to that but that was a
nice
story it was a cute idea
there's no bad ideas in brainstorming
uh again let's i i agree it's fun
but let's we've been down this road
before
let's
just five pounds okay five pounds all
right if you want to lose 10
lose [ __ ] 100 that's what we want out
of this okay but
history shows you can't you haven't been
able to do the five so setting you up
for 10
and then not hitting that the first
month is setting you up for failure the
next month mm-hmm let's do five i think
that's you you're working out
which you didn't do in l.a at all if
we're calling
if we're calling balls and strikes here
you didn't go to the gym one time all i
heard leading up to it you asked me for
the airbnb address 17 [ __ ] times
which i had sent you [ __ ]
months ahead i also brought two books i
didn't read
and then you didn't go to the gym once
it'd be one thing if you were skull and
[ __ ] ipas and beef wellington being
like oh i'm gonna get up and [ __ ]
punish myself and
you keep saying we went for a long walk
we walked two blocks it was uphill
though one way
we can't be uphill both ways it's not
the 20s on my dad's going to school
okay
so
i thought that slipped through the radar
i guess not oh no it was fully noticed
also for the record i really just wanna
i really just wanted to say the juice
starts running maybe wow
you come and beat me up
coming out of my apartment i get hit
over the head with a skateboard
is that how you would do it
oh
no
skateboard is too easily connected to me
i get luke to touch a baseball bat
hey luke let's go to batting practice
he was killed with a bass guitar
um all right let's let's let's do the
weigh-in so we agree with that five
pounds 1200 payments on the 15th of each
month
give or take a day or two because our
recording schedule okay you know what i
mean like sometimes like it might fall
on a saturday if we're not here sure
we'll make sure we're here thursday at
the earliest or monday at the latest
cool
all right i'm now taking as we've done
numerous times in the past
text you write a text and i read your
text oh is it about me yeah and what a
piece of [ __ ] i am
i'll take that as a yes
no never mind my wife texted me no go
ahead no it was i mean
uh
i feel bad you were not having fun with
that
um
god i could take it i'm looking for it
man
is it a text from a personal
acquaintance of mine
okay no
i i oh there it is um
oh no it came my uncle who we drank with
in
atlantic city you guys were just quoting
like mashed [ __ ] couple years ago
yeah
he said he sent a picture and said tell
h i'm worried about him okay and then i
said we all are that's how i talk about
you we all are what's the photo
it was
us showing the photo with santino so
it's you
it's the photo okay and it's also you
sitting next to the photo
um
he said you're gonna he goes i hope not
but it looks like you're going to be
doing that podcast alone really soon
ouch
let me see the photo
that's not me
[Laughter]
you're not even the one in the studio
all right okay
let's do this and i think we got to get
out of here right
here we go
i'm gonna get up this is the starting
point it's the way and i i
part of me is so pulling for you the the
last shred of hope i have left is so
pulling for you the only i want you to
turn this around for you not for the
[ __ ] show not for [ __ ] any you'll
be so much
happier and not dreading [ __ ] walking
to get luggage the only thing i don't
think the end of the drive the other
thing i ask you is you say
do you believe in me or no
yes
do you believe in me or no
honestly yeah no lie to me absolutely
not not even a little bit i think
there's a zero percent chance of hell
you'll ever be able to pull this off
i just told you to lie to me didn't i
i didn't you dumb [ __ ] look do you
think he has it in him
we got a big man
come on come on
t-bone i can't see you're gonna have to
do the read the big man approaches the
scale
we said whatever i weigh in is not up
for criticism dude nobody's nobody's
been harsh or criticized i've criticized
your
airbnb behavior more than your weight
t-bone's eyes just fell out of his head
[Laughter]
hang on i'm laughing it's going to go up
wait hang on a second t-bone
i want to get an honest read here
all right looks like a speedometer i
know it won't say still he's getting
better by the second
it's 406. we'll call it four wait
thank god we almost just lost four
cameras am i paying for that
what are you looking at
are we calling 406
it's jumping around a ton
all right i mean it's at 409 now
stop moving
as you move
410
settled on 410.
like a roulette machine over there my
favorite am radio station
welcome back
oh by the way welcome back to the fat
asses unfortunately somebody in the
comments on patreon said something about
inmate 403 which was [ __ ] really
funny yeah
um
but that's it so 405
one month from today one month from
today and you're clear you're 1200 bucks
okay all right so when you sit down and
you're gonna have those ipas you're
gonna whatever
could cost you twelve hundred dollars
all right and if not
you have to be either you know i'll just
withhold the money or you could come in
with cash and pay the vague
to turi
wait i didn't agree to that i didn't
agree to the vig i know i was a kid all
right jesus christ squirrely steve relax
will you these kids [ __ ] mcbones have
to get me all right i'm dude i'm i'm
beyond my better judgment and just out
of pure love i'm pulling for you thanks
buddy
rational in me no shot in hell
well see that goes that i i need an i
need you in or out
just for just for me i need you to lose
five pounds just for my files
yes when i rationally think about it no
when i i love an underdog story
everybody does or a fat big story
except for mr mcmullen doesn't it all
right we gotta wrap it up uh no hard
feelings though better choices to more
steps
to less ipas and no beef wellingtons
are you talking to
me yes what about a beef irvington
you ever have that
it's got a duck in it
gang we'll see you next week love you
peace